today on stick to football we are fixing
the New York Giants and that is a tall
order with seven draft picks it is six
million dollars in cap we're gonna break
that down also gonna answer your draft
on draft questions look at a little
stock watch from LSU Alabama a game that
we were in Tuscaloosa for at least but
Connor welcome back to our beautiful
studios it feels good to be home I'm not
gonna lie the trip to Alabama was a long
one and we are back on the road in two
weeks Stanford Cal we have a great
location set up we'll be with the
tailgate guys again so everyone come out
to that I think it will be more of like
a community style field and Alabama was
if you happen to come by that one so
we're gonna do our best to set it up
with you know some cornhole a lot of
games food drinks like always some of
our BR friends will be coming down and
then we have big big news that happened
while we were on the road to Tuscaloosa
we are partnering with Johnsonville who
makes the best brats in the world that's
not a plug like I actually believe this
and will be the ACC championship game me
you mellow tailgating right outside
mercedes-benz stadium with Johnsonville
they're doing their tailgate throwdown
there's like cooking competitions a
cornhole competition it's just gonna be
amazing and we will be there hosting it
also everybody should come check that
out oh it's gonna be awesome Sean
Alexander is gonna be there I mean it's
gonna help
won't be but Sean Alex but it's gonna be
an awesome time so just when you think
the tailgate tour is over boom we are
back for one lap maybe maybe we'll just
keep going I don't know at this point I
was gonna say I wouldn't say I'm not
ever gonna announce our tailgate tour is
over because you know the Senior Bowl is
at the end of January I wouldn't be
shocked if we end up two places between
now and then but we will be at the
Senior Bowl we will be at the Superbowl
we have someone tweet a this week like
when you guys come into the South will
be in Miami for the Superbowl Mobile
Alabama for the Senior Bowl so if you're
closer to those places get a chance to
come hang out with us but let's jump
into the news my man as we were sitting
here Tuesday morning waiting to record
Adam Schefter tweets that Vernon
Hargreaves has been cut by the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers
he was the number 11 pick in the 2016
NFL Draft coming out of Florida a player
that I really liked I had him as the
number 2 corner in that class
only behind Jay
Ramzi so a big Vernon Hargreaves fan
this was during a time something you and
I talked about before the show today
when it looked like Florida was DBU I
had burned our Hargreaves number 10
overall in that class loved his
technique he was a little bit small but
he was feisty good technique looked
fluid and he got benched on Sunday
they've really kind of said that hey
it's like a work ethic thing he's just
not there for him so Hargreaves now
subject to waivers we'll see but
probably will let you know in the Friday
show what we think of if he gets picked
up but he's owed 9 million dollars so I
actually don't know if he'll get picked
up on waivers or if there's a dude that
will clear waivers and then be a free
agent to sign anywhere he wants yeah I
think it'll be the latter because of
that money owed to Hargreaves and I know
there's a lot of teams in dire
situations at cornerback I mean two of
them just played each other this weekend
with the Jets and the Giants the Bucs
were one so the fact that the Bucs are
letting somebody go from their secondary
tells you where Vernon Hargreaves level
of play has been at listen Matt you know
he's not even come close to living up to
expectations and I think there was times
where the size was a concern but you
felt like he was a guy that can mirror
and match with good athleticism and he
really hasn't done that and forget
whether it's he's been hurt or he he
needed to move in sides of the slot the
lack of hustle to be benched is a
gigantic concern Bruce Arians it's not
gonna stand for that Todd Bowles is not
gonna stand for that I think when you
look at Hargreaves there's no way around
it he's been a gigantic disappointment
and this brings on a bigger conversation
that his draft centric is a wire Florida
corners not translating to the NFL right
now in this times of arguing who DBU is
Washington puts out great corners and
they've had their fair struggles in the
NFL as well whether it is Sydney Jones
Kevin King guys like that obviously LSU
has a lot of good and it also goes back
to safeties because someone like Marcus
may has had a really good NFL career so
far besides the injuries Brian Poole the
corner that nobody ever talks about from
Florida has been one of the better slot
guys in the league for a fan of rafted
for you an undrafted guy he developed in
Atlanta for a couple years he's been
solid for the Jets even though their
groups been miserable but tees taper you
know Quincey Wilson Vernon Hargreaves I
don't understand and now we're gonna
have a guy in this draft and CJ
Henderson
it's gonna be very very well liked how
do we take this mat when we have ace
what's clearly something going on from
the same University at the same position
yeah and it is in that time span like
2016 2017 it's really when you look at
it like what what happened here and I
think you know we always say Scott the
Scout the player not the helmet and that
is like always seem everyone in a bubble
evaluate that guy and then move on but I
mean you can look at it say it and I'll
make this a little personal as a Texas
fan when I got this job I went through
this like this learning process of why
aren't Texas players highly valued and
you would start asking around and you
would hear like oh they're coddled
they're soft
they don't know how to work there's a
sense of entitlement and so Mack Brown
was a great college head coach he was
winning a lot of ballgames but his guys
weren't really ready for the NFL because
there's kind of that like grandpa Mack
feeling around the program I don't know
if it was something similar to that with
Florida during that time span where you
know maybe there wasn't great
accountability maybe because these guys
were top-rated recruits and because they
were good players you know you just kind
of just missed it almost like I'll let
the D B's be D B's but you're right it
is tough because that 2017 2016 class
doesn't look great and even 2018 Duke
Dawson was a second-round pick by the
Patriots and they moved him this past
offseason so there's like a three-year
stretch there where they had a lot of
highly drafted guys at one position
group not perform well in the NFL so I
think how do you look at CJ Henderson
with that this is where your area scouts
are super important because they need to
have the connections that will tell the
truth so you can go to Florida and say
all right what does CJ Henderson like
what is he what's his work ethic like
doesn't go to class just go to the
weight room you know he lazy you got to
find out all the other things behind the
scenes because I think with with T's
Tabor you can chalk it up to some
laziness and I think you could chalk it
up with Vernon Hargreaves to awesome
obviously heinous and what Quincey
Wilson he said on this very podcast that
he had to grow up a little bit when he
got to the NFL so I think that's your
concern a Florida guys where you would
start that conversation is what what is
allowing them to be a little bit
entitled a little bit immature and not
ready for the NFL and that's what you
want to find out about CJ without it's
out it's it's gonna be very interesting
and that like you said it comes down to
the area Scouts and listen this is not
we're not hating on the University of
Florida they've had a
nominal season they have a phenomenal
football program but I mean Chicago
light look how quickly he fell out of
the NFL you know Chauncey Gardiner
Johnson fell down the draft for reasons
unknown it is interesting when you have
situations like this but it does come
down to a always scout the player over
the helmet moving on here but staying in
the NFL
the Bengals we talked about the
competition for the number one pick
being as close as ever finally somebody
has a little bit of a lead here as the
Bengals continue to lose football
continue to remain winless right now and
most importantly the teams around them
actually got some wins so I think when
you look at these mock drafts the
conversation has turned from well who's
going to be making selection number one
to now who is the number one pick gonna
be between Joe burrow and - it's hung by
llola and maybe chase young yeah it is
it's fascinating the Bengals are oh and
nine and we've said this a lot of the
show the Dolphins are trying to tank and
they've won two ballgames they're two
and seven the bengals weren't trying to
tank or at least we didn't think they
were and their own nine and I think all
along we've heard like a Zack Taylor's
gonna be finding to be fine also I think
the Bengals are just so cheap that
they're not gonna want to fire a guy and
pay out his contract but no way there
should be some really hard conversations
about this oh as we're recording they
cut Preston Brown a guy they gave a
three-year fifteen million dollar
contract to they need a lot of help
there that's not just player focused
something I said to mellow on the way
home from Alabama was I hope Joe burrow
doesn't go to the Bengals because I
think they'll ruin him and we've been
asked this question before like when a
player gets drafted by a certain
franchise does it affect your you're
thinking of them and what the Bengals it
does for me I don't like if they draft
Joe borough I'm gonna be sad and
disappointed because I love Joe and I
want to see him do well in the NFL
we're like the Dolphins I at least
understand what Chris Grier Brian Flores
want to do I don't agree with it and I
think you can look at Laremy Tunsil and
Myka Fitzpatrick I'm probably gonna be
all pros and it's tough to let go of
those types of players but I understand
the vision and I actually believe a
little bit in what they're doing with
the Bengals I have zero belief in this
team to lose nine straight games the NFL
is really really hard to do and now you
see how they're mismanaging Andy Dalton
one of their key free agents doesn't
even last a full season before getting
cut it's just like
one thing after another so I don't think
we have to have a conversation about
who's gonna pick first because I can't
imagine Cincinnati winning enough games
I mean the the Redskins are one and
eight right now they're really really
bad as well
but I just can't imagine Cincinnati
overtaking anyone at this point know it
you really can't and when you look at it
right now with Cincinnati and they were
honestly I think the first team we fixed
on fixing all of the teams this was not
the intentions of this team they went
out and drafted Jonah Williams in the
first round to improve this offensive
line they took true sample because they
felt like they needed a blocking tight
end where they can run the ball with Joe
Mixon they could develop the kind of
offense that Zach Taylor wants of course
the injuries don't help but at the end
of the day this is not a competitive
football team it's not it really isn't I
mean they were embarrassed by Baltimore
the embarrassed absolutely embarrassed
then I think when you look at it right
now you have to wonder how do they start
building this football team now benching
Andy Dalton and taking a look at Ryan
Finley is the ultimate signal that they
are going to take a quarterback and I
think if you were going between tua and
burrow for Zach Taylor I think to his
injuries will scare a team a little bit
like Cincinnati don't underestimate the
Midwest roots for Joe burrow who's from
Athens Ohio yeah don't yet don't people
in Ohio and I understand why love Joe
burrow this is such an easy sell for the
Bengals that the conversation has turned
to Joe burrow holding up a Bengals
jersey with the first overall pick at
the end of April and I wonder if Justin
Herbert gets in the conversation for
them because of Zach Taylor like if you
look at assuming the Zach to do exactly
what Shawn McBain having I'm not saying
it should hey you're right though you're
right well he taught he perfectly fits
what their offense wants to look like so
I think if it's the Bengals we have that
it's a three quarterback conversation I
think members the Dolphins you probably
BEC okay it's gonna be too look that's
the pick but it is gonna be fascinating
we got like four months to go five
months to go and and the quarterback
class is really heating up on the other
side of the coin no teams room
undefeated the 49ers lost a great game
on Monday Night Football and normally
this is where me as a Niners fan would
remark like oh we're just getting back
with both offensive tackles are healthy
we play without George Kittel here's
what I want to say about Monday Night
Football
Russell Wilson should be the MVP of the
NFL right now
Simon close runner-up should be Lamar
Jackson and read if you want to talk
about who's third that's fine with me
but it's Russell semadar what he did
last night Tyler Lockett went out by the
way he got hurt and it sounds like that
could be a serious leg injury so that's
terrifying because I love the
combination between those two guys
Deacon Metcalfe was like fumbling on the
one-yard line
Jermaine if Eddie is having an aneurysm
and apparently forgetting what to do
when there's a fumble like it's bad this
team around him is actually not good but
he is amazing like he's such a great
playmaker so normally I would love to
spend two minutes ranting about the
Niners I still think the Niners are one
of the best teams in all football they
got a chance to make a Superbowl run but
man what Russell Wilson is doing on that
Seattle team is the most impressive
thing I've seen in the NFL all year long
Oh without a doubt he is the MVP he's
been absolutely fantastic I mean when
you look at 23 passing touchdowns and
two interceptions he takes care of the
football as well as anybody in the
entire league he's probably the smartest
runner in the league in terms of knowing
taking what's there using what's in
front of him to his advantage to open up
the pass he's phenomenal he really is
and he and let's talk about on the other
side of the ball Jadeveon Clowney looks
like one of the best pass rushers in all
of football last night and I know the
sack numbers haven't been there this
year but it's been going on all year
where this is why John Schneider gets
the praise he gets you go out and give
up nothing for a Jadeveon Clowney and
you replaced Frank Clarke like that's
what it comes down to you like that you
replaced Frank Clark and they have draft
capital yeah I it's Seattle lost the
legion of boom and everyone was like oh
it's over but with the franchise
quarterback they have and they still
haven't done a great job building
offense a lot of him through all this
the running backs
i Rashad penny was forget that being an
awful pic Chris Carson's fumbling a lot
like you said lock it who there is their
best receiver came out Russ finds a way
to get it done and this defense with
their leader Bobby Wagner and some
ballers up front it's just truly
impressive I think them and the Ravens
are the two teams that nobody wants to
run into in the playoffs on each
conference I agree and and speaking of
the defense like I have to say it
mellows got pune ford was absolutely
amazing it's been a great fine for the
undrafted free agent or maybe he got
picked in the seventh round I think he
was undrafted but it's just it's been
fantastic how good they are and I said
this in our pre-season preview and then
we'll move on that's the last the August
thing I'll say we were like kind of down
on this roster and one thing I would I
did some easy research and it's like
listen Russell Wilson's never had a
losing season ever like things some of
the bad teams he's been on Seattle
they've never had a losing seasons like
the pride I'm gonna start having one now
I know I said last year in a tweet it
was like I wonder if he's a little
overrated I was so wrong about sending
that tweet he's actually underrated it's
like the whole script has been flipped
watching him elevate the talent around
him is absolutely amazing alright let's
move on Dwayne Haskins named the starter
the rest of the way in Washington I
think you could look at this to two
weeks
number one they feel good enough to let
him roll again there one and eight it's
not like a great football team I think
this is more of an audition than it's
been giving credit for they want to see
what they have over the next seven weeks
so that they know because they're gonna
have the one or two or three overall
pick they need to know if they have a
quarterback or if they need to draft one
because when you're picking that early
and we saw this with Josh Rosen Skyler
Murray it wasn't just about Oak Cliff
Kings where he's coming in it was that
Steve calm lost faith in Josh Rosen as
his franchise quarterback so whomever is
gonna be the head coach of the Redskins
next year and the front office is not
going anywhere that front office needs
to no case Dwayne Haskins our guy or are
we gonna let a new head coach pick his
own quarterback and now you have seven
weeks basically both nine total because
the last two but needs a huge showing I
think over the next seven weeks for us
to be absolutely certain then they're
not gonna draft a quarterback with the
top three pick yeah I think the Redskins
turned into one of the most interesting
teams in this draft and it was fun
talking to Landon Collins if you missed
that
was on our Monday show he was saying the
focus has really been there for its
Wayne Haskins now that he's locked in as
the starter he's completely obviously
bought in and just ready to go and I
think for Washington you have to wonder
they're gonna be staring in the face of
an opportunity to probably take someone
like to uh or Herbert and it's gonna be
interesting I think they should develop
a team around Twain Haskins and give him
a chance if you take a guy that raw like
we knew Dwayne Haskins wasn't a top-15
kind of player but he had promised if
you develop him this is not how you
develop a guy but it makes for an
interesting scenario where they might be
looking at that situation how they're
like hey we're bad enough we could take
another quarterback yeah and it does it
bears watching and I'm not saying they
should give up on Haskins again I liked
him I really felt like he was good for
Jay Gruden's scheme Jay Gruden's out
join Haskins could be going with him so
it's there's a lot of intrigue around
the quarterback position kind of let's
take a break we come back we're gonna
take a look back at that LSU Alabama
game but not the names that you've heard
all week long not so much Joe burrow not
so much to it but the under-the-radar
guys whose draft stock went up following
one of the greatest games we've seen a
couple in a long time it's time to talk
some draft stock following the game of
the decade Alabama LSU the Tigers pull
off the upset on the road a great game
and like we've always said in this show
you want to evaluate the best against
the best this game had 28 players on my
2020 draft board on the field so this is
one I've already rewatched it I don't
know if you've had a chance to yet
Connor but it's like this game a lot
over the next five months I want to
start with a player that really
surprised me and maybe shouldn't have
but I'm such a big fan of running back
naxi harris who like we've heard about
nagi since he was in high school and
this is a top tier running back coming
out of a prep school and he's finally
the guy and we're seeing it and his that
catch he made the back shoulder fade
that he ran not only was the throw
amazing but the catch the body
adjustment to turn his body find the
ball locate it catch it with his hands
he runs with power he runs with speed I
don't know if he can get into the first
round just because there's it's hard to
get a running back in the first round
this day and age we saw Josh Jacobs drop
to the end around one last year even
though he was a top-five player for me
with Nagi Harris I think he'll be
drafted around 2 and I think he'll be an
NFL starter and could be a high-caliber
NFL starter at the same time because he
does everything you want
I mean he's big he's fast we saw the
hands the route running he's really got
the total package I'm with you all the
way on Nagi Harris I think it was also
great to see him really mix it up in
pass protection he checks every single
box you'd want from him him when he was
coming out of the Bay Area as a
five-star prospect he was a huge deal it
was him and cam akers that was the 1a 1b
of that class and for Nagi and he
admitted this after his freshman year he
was very frustrated his lack of touches
and I think he had to wait because he's
behind NFL players non-stop and now you
see him in this feature role in his
third season with the team and he's
phenomenal his receiving ability is
great his power he's more elusive than
you'd expect for somebody that's 6 to
230 I think you just love his demeanor
on the field
I love Nagi Harris he might honestly be
a top 3 running back in this class I I
could sit here and tell you that and
nobody wants to hear this probably he
might be as good as Jonathan Taylor in
terms of probe prospects you're not calm
I'm not wrong no you're not wrong anyway
yeah he and JK Dobbins have moved up so
much for me this year because you're
seeing them do everything they're
supposed to do as prospects like that
they're doing it all and Alabama's old
line did not play well Saturday
afternoon by the way so you can't expect
oh well he plays behind Alabama's
offensive line those guys really did not
play that well so I think naxi Harris is
shooting way up my board III have him as
the number 4 running back but I would
not be surprised if he's number three or
number two when it's all said and done
he's just played that well now on the
other side of the field of running back
who we've talked about a lot on this
show
Clyde I call him Clyde the glide Clyde
Edwards a layer number 22 a little
bowling ball for LSU but my goodness
what a player like so much heart I mean
and he was showing agility he was
showing power we were sitting there
watching the second half of the game and
I told mellow and Big Tex is like guys
this is Maurice jones-drew like that's
who he reminds me of and one of them
shot back like nos Devonta Freeman it's
like well kick we just agrees really
good like whatever the yeah he's really
good and we're talking to Jacob Hester
before we record it on Saturday talking
about how guys like that when you're a
short running back how hard it can be to
locate a guy like that behind the line
of scrimmage and you see it with Clyde
because he is not only is he 5 7 he runs
low to the ground and like we said with
Kyler Murray last year short guys have a
small strike zone when you're a tackler
they're just hard to get a hat on and I
think we're seeing that with him and
then when you do get a hat on him he's
so powerful with that it was a 220-pound
frame that he's really really difficult
to get past 210 excuse me 5 8 to 10 so I
like Clyde he's probably gonna be a mid
ramp pick because he's not not the
biggest dude but he's a guy I could see
having a nice NFL career even though
he's not gonna be a priority selection
he looked amazing against Alabama when
you when he sets guys up whether it's
the spin move whether it's the power and
the leg drive and like you said Matt
those compact guys that are 5/8 and have
thick legs for that leg drive that can
really carry you down the field those
are the hardest guys to tackle and it's
funny we talk about Nagi who's six too
and a little more upright in his power
and then someone like Clyde who's very
compact and both are such great players
with different running styles this was a
fun one to watch I think nobody's draft
stock is soaring higher this week then
Clyde the glide because he wasn't really
on the radar and the top acts of this
class now it seems like the floor seems
like the third round for him when you
look at the skill set what he could do
against top competition it's great to
see a local Louisiana kid star for LSU
and one of their biggest wins of the
decade and somebody that was overlooked
he was you know either a three or four
star prospect depending what site
rankings you use and he was a star on
Saturday another guy who has been a star
all year Devon Smith and I have to admit
that I was I was too low on this dude he
is a he's a playmaker what the first
couple of times I watched him was like
man he's just so skinny he's so little
and it felt like especially where he had
the fourth touchdown game was like okay
well everyone's worried about Judy so I
don't know if Smith is actually a
playmaker in his own right well LSU
actually has the do
to put a body on everyone and a good
body on everyone and debauch the Smith
worked guys I mean one of our favorite
players in college football Derrick
Stingley jr. who's a true freshman he
looked awful and that was Devon setting
enough setting him up with his routes he
had the huge punt return and this dude's
just he's a playmaker get the ball in
his hands
you heard during the broadcast they
talked about how he has the best hands
of any of these Alabama receivers and
that shows Gerry drew D drops two
touchdown passes trying to body catch
Devon to Smith there's no body catching
withstood he has a very very good catch
radius especially for again a receiver
that's not very big I think he's listed
at 170 pounds and that might be soaking
wet he's 6 1 he is very very lean but I
see big play making skills from Devon
Smith where I just uh I would get the
ball in his hands I think we have to
talk about him as a round 1 receiver
which would put three Alabama receivers
who were all draft eligible in round one
I'm with you all the way he should be in
round one when you look at the receivers
that have dropped over the years Terry
Maclaurin it comes to mind Smith is one
of those guys where physically won't
really wow you I do think he has
underrated speed I think he's a 4/4 guy
maybe even four three nine four three
eight kind of range
he's mr. production I look I like Henry
rogue's the four to three or whatever
he's going to run is going to be amazing
he's probably gonna be great in an NFL
system that attacks the ball the tax
that feels vertically Smith's a more
productive player and it's not even
close he shows up every single game he
makes tough catches he's a tough player
I would take him round one and really
not look back I think when you look at
this class how congested the wide
receiver group is because Judy's gonna
go around one CD lambs gonna go around
one rugs is gonna go around one t
Hagen's might find his way there yeah it
might be one of those situations where
he slides out and everybody's calling on
day two to trade up for this yeah
whoever has picked 33 and the bengals
actually they should just draft him and
a parent with Tyler yeah that's easy
money the last one for me a guy who
honestly was not on my radar until this
week Jacoby Stevens I thought the LSU
secondary had a rough night now have a
straight we mentioned sting Lee had a
rough night Fulton got hurt
grant Delpit continues to
fused to wrap up when he's tackling but
Jacobi Stevens really showed himself as
you know almost a hybrid guy a lot of
times he was blitzing it seemed like he
was trying to spy to a but you could see
him pre-snap I mean he's like frantic
you know like yelling at guys getting
them set up the leadership from Jacoby
Stevens really really impressed me I
don't know if he'll come out this year
or not I'm definitely not advocating for
him to come out by listening here
listing him here but I was very
impressed with his play in a game where
I wanted to see more from Grant Delpit
and I ended up more impressed with Jacob
Phillips at linebacker and Jacoby
Stephens at safety then I really
expected to be I came away with very
similar impressions I think Stevens just
looks like the less flashy and safer you
know tough football player aspect then
tell Pitt when you see Delpit in pads he
know his ability in coverage knows
ability as a Blitzer are coming downhill
he's just missing some tackles right now
and I think that's the most important
thing for a safety is that reliability
on the back end so for Stevens in a game
where let's be honest Matt the back ends
of these defenses were more targeted and
pressured non-stop yeah for somebody
that could play up front or on the back
end it was a very very impressive
performance yeah
really was just a great game overall
like I said we're gonna be breaking it
down on our own I will probably have to
watch this game no joke a couple of
times like 12 times but just to get
through it all by the end of the year
let's take a break we come back fixing
the New York Giants get something to
drink take your shoes off because it's
gonna be a long segment try to fix this
team Dave gentlemen has a big big job
ahead of him and lucky for him he has to
stick to football guys to actually just
do his job so Dave listen up take notes
because we are going to fix your team a
projected 66 million dollars in salary
cap space that's big and right now seven
picks in the NFL Draft that will
fluctuate a little bit I believe with
the Leonard Williams deal so we'll wait
and see what happens there but as far as
free agency goes Connor who the head
coaches matters a lot
who the GM matters a lot so actually if
the Mara family were to ask me what to
do with this team I would fire them both
Dave gentlemen see ya I know there's
like you know some loyalty there and
it's nostalgic I would fire Dave
gentlemen on fire Pat Shermer
I know we've said his name a lot but I
firmly believe it Matt rule would be
really really high on my list of people
to get out of doubt he's worked for this
team he knows the area we've talked
about instilling a culture bringing a
leadership maybe not the most exciting
X's and O's guy out there he's not Sean
McVeigh or Kyle Shanahan but I think a
really good coach like a football coach
who could bring in a good staff whether
that's reaching out to Todd Monken or
reaching out to you know guys in the
college game that we could see him bring
over so I didn't Matt rule and again
there's gonna be a very very interesting
name because there's me Matt Campbell is
gonna get talk Lincoln Riley's gonna get
talk I think Matt rules the college
coach most likely to make the jump I
think so too I think there's all kinds
of rumors floating around whether you
know Adam GaSe survives in New York
whether Pat Shermer survives in New York
after Shermer took the loss the Jets the
heat is on him more than ever
Matt rule has worked for the Giants
before I think it's I think it's a hire
that makes a ton of sense
I really do now the question is are the
Giants gonna take that kind of what they
consider a risk I guess is what you
could say because the Giants are not a
team I think that this is the kind of
hire they often make where they're gonna
reach down into a program like Baylor
and hire the college guy that would
surprise me but I think this is the time
to do it I think it would be great for
the Giants I think Matt rule would go
there in a second Matt rule is from
Queens Matt rule like I said his coach
for the Giants Matt rule wanted the Jets
job last year he would definitely want
the Giants job this year I think when it
comes down to it that's where this
conversation starts now I know the dream
for a lot of people was Lincoln Riley I
still would be shocked if he went to New
York one name that's been tied to this
team that I would not like it all would
be Brian Kelly if anything happened with
him at Notre Dame I think that wouldn't
be smart the Giants are an interesting
team would they go for somebody like
Robert Solow you know what I mean like
when you look at salla like if from the
49ers right now that defense is getting
a lot of praise and that falls back on
the defensive coordinator where somebody
like salla is gonna get interviews I
don't think they would go for someone
like very young like Mike McDaniel
I don't think that
the kind of job for him although I think
he's more than ready so for the Giants
that's where this decision starts is
what do they do with this head coach but
they have to move on from pat Shermer
right and you can look at the list
because actually announce the list of
candidates last time around and josh
mcdaniels was I think kind of the
frontrunner for this job back in the day
or back in 2018 so I would wonder if
Josh McDaniels name gets thrown back in
it's been assumed that he is like the
head coach I'm waiting with a New
England Patriots so I think you have to
factor all that in you know they've
interviewed Matt Patricia he's gone
Steve Wilkes was another guy who had a
really good relationship with Dave
gentlemen I don't think Steve Wilkes has
done anything since 2018 to be
considered a head coaching candidate
same for Eric Stewartville who was with
the Broncos there's Jim Schwartz his
name's gonna be out there a lot so those
are the two where you could see like
okay maybe Schwartz maybe McDaniels but
Matt rule makes a ton of sense like you
said sallet and McDaniel from San
Francisco we're gonna get a ton of calls
McDaniel is is young a little bit
inexperienced I don't know if the Giants
would go that route someone will and
should but finding the right head coach
is the first step here now as far as
four agents go the giant well hold on
man wait are we gonna talk about if Dave
gentlemen deserves to be that have that
job or not oh he doesn't deserve to it
all I sorry I got those giant spins see
that's the problem here is that I agree
I came into doing this fixing segment
and I was like we have to fix this team
with the thought that Dave gentlemen
it's not going anywhere because I don't
think he is but Giants fans and I love
how many we heard back from when we
announced we were doing this we're like
you need to start with firing him and I
want to let them know that we agree with
them oh yeah without a doubt
yeah clearly and you know I don't think
he would take it and I haven't asked him
if he would be okay with me saying this
so here goes forgiveness is better than
permission I would call Daniel Jeremiah
and I know a lot of people think they're
like oh these TV guys Dana Jeremiah is
not a TV guy he was a scout for three
teams and like yes high level scout
right like not even a scout leader of
college scouting yeah and like listen
the job that may aux doing is very very
admirable he's doing a really good job
and DJ has more scouting a more
organizational executive experience than
mike Mayock there's a reason Joe Douglas
one a lot of teams have wanted him so I
don't know if he'd be willing to move
from the west coast to the east coast
but the Giants are like that's a
prestige job like listen I would take
the job if they wanted to hire my dumb
ass like there's just there's that's one
of the jobs you can't say no to so
obviously you know like ed Dodds is
gonna get a lot of play Mike bergen's
he's gonna get a lot of play
I think DJ would be up there elliot
wolf's name a couple years ago was like
red-hot I think that that has really
started to die down to where when he was
in Green Bay it was like oh he's one of
the hottest young names in football I
don't really think it is anymore
so if it were me if I had to put my name
on three dudes Daniel Jeremiah be atop
my list edie odds be second I might
borgen's he was with the Chiefs to be
third and there's those others out there
there's a couple dudes in Seattle who
are really good and they've interviewed
for jobs you a fitter or
jets job yep so like there are good
scouts out there good directors out
there but I'm telling you Daniel
Jeremiah be the top of my list I can't
disagree with that I just wanted to talk
about this GM conversation because it's
one that needs to it needs to happen we
have to have a conversation about it
yeah my bad I thought it was just
assumed so moving on to the guys who are
actually free agents Leonard Williams
obviously whoever the GM is as a
decision to make here if they want to
sign him because they don't sign him the
draft pick compensation changes Marcus
golden who has had some good playing
spots by here and then David Mayo those
are like the key free agents that's it
so not a lot of key free agents on this
team some of that is because I haven't
drafted that well so like they're not
and I really tried to hold on to guys I
would keep Leonard Williams self and not
because I'm a huge Leonard Williams fan
as far as what he's done in the NFL but
because you gave up picks to get him you
gave up a third-round pick for a guy I
think you have to resign him I'm with
you as well I don't really understand
this trade because I for all the times
we don't like what the Giants do I
actually like their interior defensive
line a lot and I think with Leonard
Williams I think he's happy to stay in
New York he's ripped by Vayner sports
who are based out of New York so I think
they would like to keep him here and I
think it's gonna cost the decent amount
of money I think that's the problem and
I think it goes back to something that
I had a huge problem with his and I know
we just talked to him so it might seem a
little biased but we felt like this
before it I still don't know why this
team didn't franchise tag Landon Collins
with the money they have the lack of
players they need to resize you didn't
have to give him what the Redskins gave
them but I don't really know why he why
they just let him go I really can't
explain it and that goes back to another
reason why I don't know why Gettleman is
here but let's stick to the let's stick
to the fixing here I think they do have
to Reese I lettered Williams you gave up
a third-round pick that is now going to
be a top of the third round pick right
for the New York Jets you gave up a
fifth round pick that will turn into a
fourth if you do resign him before free
agency which they probably will I still
think Leonard Williams is very young and
can be impactful and something we're
gonna get to when we do the mock draft
which I lied to you Matt I didn't I'm
doing a mock draft they need to solve
the edge pass rushing group and that
might help Leonard Williams on the
interior a little bit yep they
absolutely do and it is tough with with
their lack of picks to get an edge
rusher because they have so many other
needs so when it goes to free agency I
think I had three names somehow one got
deleted from the rundown I would throw a
lot of money at Jana kinkaku and I know
like they've in the past like Oh we'll
get Olivier fern in it and that and
really work out I think some of that was
scheme as well as anything else like as
it changed Yannick egaku is gonna be one
of the best pass rushers on the market I
don't feel like this is a team that's
gonna get edged Damien clowny he's
probably gonna stay in Seattle I don't
think that Von Miller is gonna come up
and actually be a free agent
you gotta get Gok away someone you have
66 million that's where most of my
money's gonna go so sign Leonard
Williams signed Yannick aqaq way that's
gonna help on the edges a ton now two
other names that I would look at that
could be low end or middle tier for
agent signings Jack Conklin the Titans
decided not to pick up his fifth year
option after he was an all pros of
rookie and then struggled for two years
he's actually playing pretty well this
year healthy finally which is huge for
him he's healthy Jack Conklin is a
starter at right tackle for the New York
Giants
so Mike rumors leaves just bring in Jack
Conklin I think this is an improvement
he's a young guy and again if he's
healthy
at one point time I don't think he
deserved it but he was named an All Pro
so pretty good player and then I would
look at Darryl Worley
the corner group and free agency is not
expected to be great and where the
Giants are drafting
I don't know that they're gonna be able
to get an impact corner and fill some of
their other needs so I think Darryl
Worley he and G Andre Baker
like that's a good group and I think
general Jenkins is probably gone so you
would have Sam Beale John Dre Baker Cory
Ballentine and then bring it Darryl
Worley that's a group that you can work
with at the corner position because you
have two safeties who are pretty solid
and Antoine Bethea and mr. Pro peppers
yeah I'm with you all the way I think
that's how you really rebuild it
especially when you look at Conklin when
there was a lot of questions around him
it's clear that it was just injury
related now the big concern is the
Giants tried this before with Nate's
older and I think they signed damaged
goods but he had what looked like
chronic back problems I don't think
Conklin has that kind of issues at this
stage of the game we saw the Giants deal
with three holes on the offensive line
against the Jets due to injuries so they
do need to add plenty of depth of this
unit it's something that has to be
addressed addressed in free agency it's
something that has to be addressed in
the draft and I think this would be a
really promising start for them you're
not trying to build Rome in a day here
now for all of the problems Pat Shermer
has had I actually think a lot of the
play calling has tailored to Daniel
Jones's strengths where it's helped him
develop where if you get some of these
pieces in place it gives him a much
better chance to succeed well let's get
some more pieces Matt it's time to do
our mock drafts
yeah and it's tough because they said
where they pick they have seven
selections right now and currently I
actually want to make sure this didn't
change based on last night because I did
my my mock draft yesterday currently
they would pick number three overall so
that has not changed we can safely
assume the Bengals are taking a
quarterback and the Redskins are taking
chase young so I'm not putting chase
young here even though he will obviously
be the pick like duh that's the pick so
I think they would have a conversation
at this point about Jerry Judy and about
Jeff Okuda what's it gonna be do you
want a top-flight wide receiver who
looks like the guy you just traded to
the Cleveland Browns and Odell Beckham
or do you want a corner who is gonna end
up one of the highest ranked corners
that I've seen in the last ten years I
don't know who the GM will be I know who
the head coach will be but I believe
this will come down to they need to help
Daniel Jones sterling Shepherds
concussion situation is terrifying
I don't know that you can count on him
being a fixture of this team moving
forward Evan
from her often they need assets in the
passing game I think that's why you go
jerry judy here over jeff akuto who i
really really like
but judy is the number three player on
my big board I think he makes too much
sense for the Giants
yeah I can't disagree with that pick in
this scenario I can't now for the Giants
here's what you want you want to keep
losing and you want to get chase young
and yes that is stating the obvious here
but you want whoever's picking one and
two to take quarterbacks and chase young
falls right into your lap because that's
the quickest way that's basically your
nick Bosa scenario where I'm not saying
you'd be the 49ers next year because you
don't have Kyle Shanahan sorry
but when it comes down to it chase young
can impact a football team next year
like Nick mosa has impacted the 49ers
this year where that's the dream pick at
number one but I do agree with Matt's
fallback option I think Jerry Judy is
good enough to be the number one wide
receiver for Daniel Jones with a third
overall pick at pick number 35 overall
we addressed the right tackle spot in
free agency I think they have to address
the left tackle spot in the NFL draft
now a lot of people are gonna be saying
why not an edge rusher remember I went
Jana can gawk wave for agency if they
can't get an edge rusher threw for
agency then yeah you would consider a
guy here but I'm gonna go offensive
tackle left tackle Austin Jackson at USC
he's a little young and a little raw but
the size is there the athleticism was
there the quickness is there I think one
of the only concerns is inside power and
that can be developed that the Giants
also have two pretty good offensive
guards so I'm not as worried about that
inside shoulder with him I think Austin
Jackson just a junior so maybe he
doesn't come out I mean he does come out
he's gonna end up in the top 40 picks
based on not just potential but his
readiness it's rare to see an athletic
left tackle with a mean streak and he
definitely has that yeah he really does
I think we've been talking about him a
lot these last two weeks as some
something of a riser a little bit in
just the tools that he has now I went
with the offensive line as well and
somebody that we saw on Saturday here
and somebody we've watched over these
last two years
Jedrek wills I think he's mean I think
he's nasty I think the play experience
he has from being on Alabama in the SEC
is something that the Giants especially
with gentlemen
would highly highly value I think the
key here is the Giants have what you
would consider still holes on this
offensive line and specifically probably
right tackle for next year
I think wills could be a plug-and-play
right tackle that would really open up
what they want to do and that's run the
ball with say Quan Barclay yep I really
like wills I thought he actually played
better than Alex Leatherwood who
disappointed we had a tough game did
Kayla Vaughn chase on did not have a
tough game he had a really good round
for picked 99 and this would be a debut
at Olympic it's actually something I
would do as well I think the linebacker
cord needs an upgrade to the point where
like when the Giants were picking 5th
and 6th I really liked them as a spot
for Isaiah Simmons but here's a name
that we have not talked about enough
chess rat at North Carolina he has been
on fire this year his production is
outstanding he could play metal
linebacker whether they're sticking to
this three-four there and now or they go
to a 4-3 he's a redshirt junior and he's
not the biggest dude one thing I like
about him he's not gonna have to leave
the field in Nichols situation so yeah
he's a little bit undersized he's
probably gonna be flagged as a hybrid by
some people but I like his play in the
middle of the field let him roam let him
drop into zones let him chase the
quarterback a little bit he's shown for
the Tar Heels this year just amazing
production you know all three phases of
the game for a linebacker so not a not a
priority pick but a top 100 guy for me I
really like that pick I struggled to
find a linebacker with the draft picks
they had and this is why I kind of wish
they still had that third round pick
because that's the sweet spot where you
might be able to find a gem at the off
ball off ball linebacker position I just
couldn't do it in the fourth round here
I kind of took a BPA approach I took
Keyshawn Vaughn because yes when sacrum
Barclays hurt they need something better
at the running back position but I think
you can play Vaughn with say Kwan as a
pass catching home-run-hitting kind of
running back that could probably find
his way on special teams as well the
Giants can't be in a position where when
se Kwang goes down the offense goes down
and I think later in this trap they
should find some insurance with the
speedy running back ya know I like that
pick a lot around five pick one 31 I
went back to the corner position again
even if they get guys afraid you see
John Orr's Jenkins has gone Sam Beal
we liked him as a supplemental draft guy
but he has not flashed much at all so
I'm going to a camera dancer from
Michigan State someone who I like his
size six to 185 a redshirt junior so
again might not come out but maleic he's
leaning that way this is one thing that
I think they need in the secondary is
more size they need physical guys who
can match up you know with the Asha and
Jeffries someone who can press Terry
McClaren at the line of scrimmage guys
who can you know bang with Amari Cooper
they need more size at the corner
position so I like Cameron dancer I mean
he's gotten worked a little bit this
year it's a bad Michigan State team
which I think makes him a little bit of
a tough projection but 6 to 185 and
physical at the line of scrimmage that's
something I'm gonna take a chance on
this late in the draft and they need to
they need more corners they really
really do and that's why I went with
corner as well this guy would play in
the slot though that's Myles Bryant from
Washington he's tough he's feisty but
like we always say on the show he's just
tiny he's really a smaller guy and
that's gonna cause him to slide
especially if he doesn't run well but I
think he can mix it up for this Giants
secondary where you know we haven't seen
a lot of Sam Beal I actually think he
played for the first time this weekend
jinora Jenkins isn't gonna be there
anymore they are really gonna have to
take some swings at corner so you went
for the guy with length that could play
on the outside I went for the guy that's
a little quicker and feisty er for the
inside giants probably need one of each
of those well speaking of undersized and
quick that's where I went in round six
pick 163 with Darryl Taylor from
Tennessee just Senior Bowl yeah so it
will be excited to see him I like Taylor
and people might think oh this is kind
of late for him he's so not undersized
he's like 6 4 but he's kind of skinny
like when I watch him plays like ok yes
a really good first step but he really
doesn't have a whole lot of power so I
like Taylor he has a chance to impress
me I have the senior bowl at the combine
right now he looks more like a
situational pass rusher so I think
that's why you get him late but if
you're willing to stand him up and again
he's probably a third down guy at least
to begin with but maybe can develop add
some strength and become an everyday
player round six you're betting on a
trait basically his first step trait is
good enough for me yeah I'm with you
they did that without shame ximena's
last year I say cup stacking the deck
and get more pass rushers and nobody
gets sacks and bunches like Daryl Taylor
so if he's on a good Darryl
we can senior bowl nobody will be able
to block him it's gonna be hilarious to
see I want what Kendal Coleman from
Syracuse so they take a bit of what
would be a local guy here Coleman had
ten sacks last year and I thought would
be in the conversation as a day to you
player in this draft it just hasn't been
there Matt it hasn't been there for this
defense the production hasn't been there
maybe because of the traits people do
take him earlier than the sixth round
but two and a half sacks this year
Syracuse just kind of treading water and
I think what's been a disappointing
season for their standards and what they
expected but I still think Coleman can
play and in the sixth round like Daryl
Taylor why not take him and see what he
could do to get upfield against the pass
he picked up a senior bull invite as
well I think I think I saw that all
right pick 195 the last one around seven
I'm gonna go safety here try to build
depth in the secondary because I went
wide receiver early and that that's a
philosophy of mine you draft a
quarterback almost every year and the
year you don't have to quarterback like
load up on receivers and secondary
players because you can get athletes
late and those skills translate a lot
better than I just draft another
offensive lineman I would always take
safeties corners receivers late and a
quarterback like every other year so
having said that Jalen Elliott a safety
for Notre Dame can come in I think
number one he could be a special teams
player that's one thing I love about
Notre Dame you're gonna see guys like
Jalen Elliot you're gonna see Gillman
you see chase Claypool like they're
gonna play special teams so I know he's
ready they're really good size at 6 1
208 this is a really good backup to
Jabril Peppers type guy who again can
maybe be a third or four safety but
could definitely help on special teams
yeah and I went with that theory of
viewers to take these kind of players
lay only on the wide receiver and
Antonio Gandy golden he feels like he's
been the small school golden child this
year coming out of Liberty but he's
built like an NFL player
six-four two-twenty I actually think
he'll run well for that size the
production's been great we're gonna know
a lot about this guy
after the Senior Bowl because I want to
see him get off the line I want to see
him and one-on-ones against these
quarterbacks that'll be in the NFL
that's the time where you go and show
hey I should've been playing at Liberty
I should have been playing in the SEC
the pac-12 the big 10 big 12 where you
have 3,000 yards every year doesn't
matter so I think when you look at Gandy
gold and the giant
done a nice job with late round
wide-receivers I think Darius Slayton
has been a phenomenal find for them this
year keep stacking the deck and see what
else you can find yeah gonna be a lot of
fun all right let's take a break last
one of the show we come back it is draft
on draft time it is draft on a draft
time we got four great ones today
starting with our guy Robert with two
B's I'm trying to grade slash ranked
players on my big board does it ever
happen that a player with the lower
grade ranks higher than a player with a
higher grade just based on positional
value so for me no like top players top
players the only way positional value
comes in is if there's a tie so say on
like the this scouting grade scale that
I use like say they're guys who are both
7.0 well the positional value or the
player I feel better about it's gonna be
higher so I only shuffle guys with the
same grade like tiebreakers are
sometimes positional value for me if
that I hope that makes sense it does in
my head it makes a lot of sense I think
the way Robert with two B's is framing
this question is more of how a
decision-maker would frame it where
teams would make a board and it goes by
player grade but they will draft a
player with a lower grade plenty of
times
yeah that's available because they need
the position need you know the coaches
like the player better but for us
strictly as evaluators I don't do that
like I have running backs in my top 30
every year I was just looking back at
the class from two years ago because I
wanted to see where I had guys like
Lamar Jackson and Ronald Jones and I
think that Ronald Jones is like a top 32
player and it's like no team you don't I
mean like what are the chances Ronald
Jones was going in the first round it's
kind of the point
so it's grades are just so different
than positional value and how you would
draft the player and all that stuff and
it really keeps it simple if you just go
by strictly what the grade is yep it for
us like again that's four I think that's
where a difference between media and
team evaluation is so key and like we
could have a conversation about that
every show and never run out of material
because it is it's so important
situation and environment scheme all
that so it's a good question
Garth
ask what's your take on Cougars
Washington State Cougars quarterback
Anthony Gordon will the fact that he
couldn't beat out Gardner Minshew hurt
him
so I liked this question for a number of
reasons Anthony Gordon's an interesting
guy because ya put up huge numbers for
Washington State as they do but also
this idea that a players not good if he
couldn't beat out another player it's
fascinating to me
I dealt with this over the weekend
people like if Joe Burrell were good he
would have beat out Dwayne Haskins
Dwayne Haskins threw for 50 touchdowns
and was a Heisman finalist as a 1 year
starter so no it's not so it's not that
simple not to pile on my guy Garth this
just is a launching off point number one
also Joe Barbaro got hurt and was us
focuses on basketballs to join Haskins
was able to win that job but I don't
subscribe to this belief that X player
couldn't beat out Y player so they're
not good because there's a lot that goes
into that Gardner Minshew was a player
that Washington state was the only
school that really offered him a chance
to play I'm sure Mike Leach loved him
also like Gardner's leadership skills
are gonna keep a lot of really good
players on the bench having said all
that I'm the Athan Gordon's a late round
pick at best he's like 185 pounds he's
just not a very big guy he's skinny I
think you have to throw out a lot of
what they do in that scheme and as a
redshirt senior like you just get your
got one year tape and unless he has
those incredible you know intangibles
that Minshew has then it's gonna be hard
for me to get excited about him yeah I
think that was the difference in minsu
honestly without his intangibles I don't
think men she would have been shafted
and you could sit and look back on it
and be like well everyone miss then
because they did man she was
outperformed expectations up by a mile
there's not a lot of Gardner Minshew
Zinn the world just like there's not a
lot of deck Prescott's in the world not
a lot of Russell Wilson's not a lot of
Tom Brady's so when it comes down to it
do I think Gordon is one of those guys
right now I don't have him as one do I
think he could get drafted sure you
probably can I just think you have to
ask what is his ability physically and
what hides him in this system because
this system is notorious for putting up
you know mediocre talents or guys with
mediocre traits put up really really
soaring kind of numbers one thing that
we have changed with Draft 400 this year
like organizing our thoughts the first
question we asked about every player is
what's his best trait what she's elite
trait was what what does he do well
start there for me don't let's not even
get into like size and all that other
stuff like what does he do well and if
you can't answer that question about a
guy's like okay you're in trouble why
are we talking about it and I think what
so with Gordon and with Anthony Gordon
what is his elite trait I don't have it
right now I don't either so you're gonna
hear that a lot over the next five
months you're gonna get tired of it but
my scouting philosophy right now and it
sucks because this is actually how I was
taught to scout and I got away from it
is what does he do well was he great at
there we go
that's where the conversation starts not
how does he project to the NFL scheme
what does he do this pro style nope nope
was he do well so Melo is gonna get so
tired of me asking him that questions
give me amazing right stick to football
the Ocho I think this is a fan account I
still am not sure if it's a troll or a
fan I'm gonna go a fan how did Joe
burrow and to a chunk of although a
stack up against the 2017 2018 and 2019
quarterback prospects this is a tough
question because I am NOT ready to put a
number grade on those guys yet it also
like this requires a ton of hindsight
where we go back and say like okay I had
tribus key and deshaun Watson tied I had
Trebek ease QB 1 but their grades
numbers tied and then I had my Holmes
right below that so it's like okay based
on those grades for the league obviously
I like these guys better in terms of a
number grade but once you factor in like
how you were wrong about those guys it
really becomes difficult so I did not
love the 2017 quarterback class I didn't
have anyone ranked in the top ten I
don't think I'd any one of the top 15
even 2018 I like to say I'm darn old and
Josh Allen like Josh wasn't like Baker
so at all for those guys in the top 12
so it just it gets tough I think on his
number grade burro will probably be
similar to Sam dharna would be my guess
okay that's high that's very high and
then last year like I didn't like anyone
last year my top quarterback last year
was Tyler at 13 overall so I guess
kind of liked him but yeah yeah I would
guess burr will be right around where
Sam dharna was and to uh to his injuries
just but they scare me so much yeah
they're scary I will see their I don't
think I'll have either of them graded
higher than I had Watson and Kyler so ID
Kyler fourth overall last year which is
extremely high extremely high
Watson was my QB one I don't know where
I had him on the big board
I had Rosen and Baker very high I had
them as top ten prospects that year I
had Lamar Jackson a couple spots over
darn 'old but I liked both of them
enough where they were top 25 prospects
so I think burrow and - oh we'll lean
somewhere in the middle of those guys
where I don't think I'll have them
higher than Watson Kyler Rosen Baker
maybe right around there it's like I
don't I'm the first and foremost to say
I don't think burrow and Toa are
necessarily special and when I say that
I mean I don't think they're elite
quarterback prospects like you can find
flaws in both of them yeah but I think
they're good quarterback prospects and
similar to the last couple years where
Kyler Watson rose and Baker those guys
were all on my top tens I think - and
boro we'll both finish in my top tens so
it's it's very like it's a standard year
in my eyes like they're they're not luck
we always go back to like where like
everybody looked at Andrew Luck and they
were like he's gonna be great and if you
don't think so you're an idiot and he
was when he played he was great he was
absolutely great
so it's interesting it's very
interesting I think it's hard to answer
this question though Matt for me without
having actual number grades on them
right now
yeah and I'll say I think our number
grading skills changing this year for
Draft 400 so I know that's gonna throw a
bit of a bump at the road as far as
historical comparisons go so that is he
may get tough but it's trying to evolve
like I've been feeling this job 10 years
still trying to get better at it
right so trying to make things better
for us better for the readers but if
your listeners everything right Alex
Curtis
longtime listener first-time caller I
know you guys like to talk traits but as
Fromm's lack of production this year
worried
anyone in the scouting community I'd yes
yeah there are a lot of things that
slight pause there are a lot of things
with from that worried me and this is a
part of a bigger conversation we can
have about like environment is gonna
matter for Jake from like where he goes
and why he's asked to do it's gonna
really dictate whether or not he's a
good in FL quarterback I I think he's a
round 2 guy who if he were bigger or at
a bigger arm or had better production
you could bump him to round one but I
I'm gonna keep him around too if he
comes out this year for what like what I
was saying before what's his elite trait
his elite like his best trait might be
his toughness like he's second theres
probably accuracy but like yeah the
production bothers me a little bit I
think some of that's also just that
offense like it's just not you know this
isn't the big 12 where guys are throwing
for 700 yards a week but yeah I think
there was from you could definitely say
like alright we would love to see you
take over a game dude and just you know
have your deshaun Watson moment or your
Lamar Jackson omen or you know he'll
even like Joe burrow had one Saturday
twoa has had them Trevor Lawrence has
had them like what's Jake Fromm's
signature game where you tell me hey go
watch him play and you're gonna think
this dude's the NFL quarterback I don't
know what game that is and like said
this year only 13 touchdowns you know
some of that is all the players he lost
last year to the draft obviously is
having an effect but I think it's a
legitimate concern I think it is I think
if you're looking for the game where he
makes plenty of NFL throws I thought
there was a lot and they were really
incompletions cuz it drops and stuff and
against Notre Dame this year now
if you want to make the argument for
Jake from you could go back and say well
his system holds him back
Joe borough system really held him back
last year absolutely and Joe burrow in
this new system with Joe Brady has been
phenomenal and I'm not saying if Jake
Fromm stayed and transferred to LSU and
played in that system he would have the
year Joe burrows having but I think he
could yeah I think there's a chance I
don't think Jake Fromm is this
overwhelmingly physically impressive
quarterback but I think he's brilliant
and I think he can make really nice
touch throws with accuracy and
understand where pressures coming from
that stuff translates to the NFL so are
there concerns in the scouting community
of course otherwise he'd be right in the
conversation with two and burrow and the
conversation around him wouldn't be hey
he's going back to school right but I
still think there are a lot of things to
like about him we've had this
conversation off the air before I with
Jake from it's like you watch him it's
like there's like this could be drew
Brees you know a smaller really smart
tough quarterback with touch accuracy or
this could be Andy Dalton and like I
feel like that's the trajectory for him
and it will matter where he goes and the
targets around him and what he's asked
to do but like he's gonna be solid which
is why I said he's ranked number 36 on
my board right now
excuse me 34 cuz that board needs it
needs uh re numbered so I like Jake from
oh I get that wrong but I'm not blown
away to where if I were the Bengals I
would consider him at number one overall
or the Dolphins at number four overall
he feels more like a guy that like go to
the Chargers to replace Phillip Rivers
yeah go to the Rams Yeah right yeah good
yeah it's gonna be fun this quarterback
classes is great nice to meet you a lot
of fun to talk about that is our show
though we'll be back Friday morning
Connor Mello and myself breaking down
the upcoming weekend it's a good college
football weekend let's go to NFL weekend
and we're gonna have a fun top five for
you guys so come back Friday morning
subscribe on Apple podcast stitcher
Spotify and don't forget we are on
YouTube as well so check all that out
and we will talk to y'all real soon